so let me make just a few introductory
remarks and then I'll
over things to to dug into to gym
yesterday I'm sorry last Thursday
discussion I think few things we need to
maybe highlight and one that bears
repeating in this in this class and that
is class on faith and faiths and
globalization is that fates do not have
monopoly on values less some of you who
aren't of any particular faith thing
that that's being communicated in this
class but religions are as I've said
many times here about self social
relations and the good and just because
they are about those things they are
also about values and I think it's
important to keep in mind that religions
aren't primarily telling people what to
believe they aren't primarily also
telling people what to do they're
primarily kind of sketching the kind of
world people inhabit and therefore
giving accounts of what it means to lead
one's life well and I think so also do a
various humanist perspective so also I
think but the kind of set of values is
embedded in kind of business practices
and also in the science dominant modes
of science that explains business
practices in our economic life i was
talking to doug over over lunch
yesterday about some of these some of
these things sure values are embedded in
that that was that that's exactly right
even when they're not explicitly stated
selves as discrete individuals who are
maximizing their own utility one social
relations as kind of modes of
contractual relationships we are traders
in wide variety of relationship that we
have as this thing from say in
traditional societies where people saw
themselves as fundamentally givers or
remember the stacks that we read from
gita right which is a text about you
know fundamental relationship that you
have to all all people and your whole
whole reality is that of receiver of a
gift and giver of gifts and i suppose
there is also embodiment of the idea of
the goods
mark markets which maximize utility
judged by revealed preference and that
account of self that account of the
social relations and the good also has
its own explicit and values that can be
coded and are embedded because they're
embedded in it and sometimes then
religious values and values that are
embedded in markets themselves and
business practices they collide and in
that sense I think we need to reflect
also about the relationship between
faith and globalization as it relates to
market as I have suggested in our
discussion last time I want to
differentiate between the two ways in
which values bear upon economic activity
one is I said function internal
functioning of the markets and the two
is kinds of values that are brought to
bear on the purposes in the ends of
economic activity and I think that
applies also of not just a market as a
whole but certainly applies also to
individual enterprises and to
corporations I will make two more set of
comments and then I'll pass a pass it on
to dog and one is about values worldly
goods and faith traditions just to frame
a bit more continued framing a bit more
what we're doing and then the other one
about what can be described as kind of
spirituality of work especially the text
that we read on on kind of Gita
reflection of what it means to to work
well because that type of reflection is
present in most faith traditions we
haven't done much with it but it's a
very very important aspect of faith
traditions and I'll say just a few words
about that so values worldly goods and
faith traditions and I take it that from
perspective of internal to the
functioning of the market or individual
corporation or even globalization
processes as a whole fades up here
either as kind of dysfunctional right if
they interfere with the processes is
there
our supposed to to run or they may be
functional in a sense in that they are
helping along they may be either either
the sand or they may be oil in the in
the in the larger machineries so the
important for from that perspective is
fades functional utility and and goal
might be then of course to reduce this
function and to improve on function
right fades utility might be consistent
that but from the perspective of fades
that can be how things look like him
because the perfect of fate see
themselves as overarching perspectives
and therefore there's a strong
resistance about thinking of faith
simply mayor is simply in terms of their
utility for whatever purpose it is that
we that we have in mind so I think fades
more ask the question how do we make
sense of what we're doing how do we
evaluate what we are doing which is kind
of a moral assessment how do we
strengthen the mend and transform which
is a kind of practical engagement issue
and so so that so that sort of fades
themselves see them see themselves as
both providing the framework of meaning
and also steering the processes and that
gives fades a certain kind of preachy
characteristic as I was discussing the
other day with with Joel about about
this that they can appear as a kind of
moralizing and this is annoying
especially if people if they don't
understand processes at hand but then
wag their fingers at you all the time
right then then then things become
become rather rather rather difficult in
resistances are are great and maybe
that's why it's important to keep in
mind that fates aren't primarily about
commands fates are primarily about
situating the self in the broader
account of reality and in many ways I
think many many fates would think
certainly Christian faithful thing that
it's primarily not about following rules
but it's about perceiving life as a gift
and one's own sense of giftedness and
responsibilities out of giftedness
rather than kind of structuring simply
life as such in any case I think this
moralizing attitude isn't so terribly
helpful you know I'm I have been
schooled some of you mentioned I think
to say that I've done my doctoral work
on Karl Marx and and those of you who
have read Karl Marx you know the big
debates between between kind of utopian
socialists and consented scientific
Marxist then one of the big debates was
right that utopian socialist their
finger wagging folks right and marks I
think rightly pointed out that you can
just wag fingers around against reality
it's you've got to kind of respect the
inner dynamics and development of
realities and I think that's what I
suppose people of faith often need to be
reminded off now let me switch to the
idea of spirituality of work and as I
mentioned earlier there's a kind of long
tradition in in various faiths to think
about work particularly significance of
work in human life its relative
importance and work not understood
simply as means to an end although that
too it is but as a form of being human
you need in some tradition like in
Christian Jewish traditions as a end I
think to some degree also in Muslim as
being form of likeness to divine
creativity proper goals of work what it
is it is appropriate to achieve with
work and then the character of work as
an action
often reflection of work as a form of
worship work and service unto the divine
right you see how work is then taken out
of simple reference to oneself and
placed into the wall indeed cosmic
framework I mean tilling of the ground
by a single lonely individual placed in
the cosmic framework you may say well
that's from certain perspective secular
projected economy lunacy right from
other perspective you can see how large
of a sense of the self had that of its
own situatedness and implications of
what is being done in this single
repetitive kind of activity I think
which is a venom is extraordinary in the
text that we read from reflections on
work from the Gita kind of sense of
detached involvement is has been has
been emphasized and it's interesting to
compare what's happening there with what
in that text with what you find in some
of the upper hammock traditions non
detachments to the fruits of action
realization of one's higher self in the
process of work the whole reflection of
what it means to actualize oneself which
self is this that is being actualized in
work and in particular also this idea of
work as giving as exercise in generosity
at the table today we were with ability
of a TAS we've been discussing and then
John John has mentioned that in many
ways you've got very opposite idea in
some of the religious tradition
traditions from what you have in Adam
Smith right you pursue work for others
it's only so that the benefit of others
is being achieved but in gita it's very
interesting right you have ever this one
text where it says well when you give
you actually give not so sort of say to
achieve the good but the good gets to be
achieved so to say behind your back as
you're engaged in gift-giving because
your life is inserted again in this
cosmic framework where things are
returned
into you from other source which you
give in generosity towards toward others
even similar notions I think in the
Christian Christian tradition as well
though there I take it that primary
purpose of work is something like a
better mental world in service to God
and if you take a look at the first book
of Genesis first book of the Bible in
Genesis you will see something of that
of that sort human work is there not
simply to satisfy one's own needs but to
satisfy the needs of the community and
indeed in this very interesting sense
human work is there in a sense to make
the world itself a human world which is
which is you have interesting piece but
the story of the creation which goes and
God created human beings and so forth
but there weren't yet the what
vegetation wasn't yet there because
there was not rained had not yet fallen
and there was not a man there to till
the ground so in a sense in a very if
you want to say a naive form you have
explication of the need for there to be
a natural process as combined with
cultural processes in order to create a
human world and i think that's idea of
human work as directed toward the
creation of a habit world as a habitat
for humanity again you see how widely
stretch the idea it is right it's almost
like a philosophy of history is embedded
it rather than simply consumption of
work I work in order to get a paycheck
at the end of the end of the week or
whenever that comes and that too is then
inserting the idea of work is calling
and participation in divine work right
that brings the question of values but
values not simply as again commands
but values as goals values as
large-scale perspectives into which our
lives including our economic activity
are always already seen as being
inserted I have less than one minute and
I'm done